hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Walking Dead QA one episode
left just remember it's a 90-minute
finale so there's like an extra 30
minutes of footage or actually
technically it's like an extra 40
minutes a lot of you are also asking
about the schedule for the rest of the
year like with the spin-off and when
walking dead season six is premiering so
I tried to work that into the QA just
careful for spoilers because there was
actually one really big Morgan related
question that I wanted to start with a
lot of you are asking about these
mysterious looking body parts here that
look like an african-american with a
wedding band and a pair of glasses that
look mysteriously like the pair of
glasses that Morgan was wearing there
are two big possibilities one Morgan got
to Alexandria before the others did and
was exiled he was part of that exile
group got killed by the wolves and those
are his body parts the other possibility
which i think is a little more likely is
that that's just a reminder for Morgan
and we will see his story during the
finale even if he is dead even if those
are his body parts and he's already dead
where we are on the show right now in
the timeline we will still see what
happened to him I would be so pissed
that they just completely dropped his
storyline I don't think they're gonna do
that sometimes they get a little weird
with the way they tell stories so I
think they're going to be jumping around
in time a lot during the finale don't
worry though Morgan is coming whether or
not it be in flashback or in present day
he is coming here we go there are no
questions let's do the thing young
nation asks do you think that whenever
the safe zone gets attacked or overrun
by walkers that people like Jesse
Francine and Aaron will become new
members of the survivors I I definitely
think that the groups will integrate
much more in season 6 some people will
totally die but I do think that they
will integrate by season 6 Robert
Kirkman said they were doing more stuff
from the comics so I'm really interested
to see how fast they speed along to the
other big locations in the comics
Alexandria safe zone isn't like the end
point for the series it's a big
destination but there are a lot of other
big places from the comics of the show
could go I think it would be completely
weird if they vacated the safe zone
immediately at the start of season 6
next question Chris asks do you think
that Morgan is going to join the group
well I mean it really depends on whether
or not that body that chopped-up body is
Morgan I do think that he would join the
group if he's alive he will join the
group take that with a grain of salt you
know i'd love to see morgan join the
show full time
even if he's alive and he joins the
group it doesn't mean that he's going to
stay with the group forever we'll have
to wait till they finish telling this
this Morgan side story that's been going
on in season five I think if that turns
out to be really interesting if they
write a really interesting end for
Morgan then I'd be much more willing to
accept like a side Morgan plot going
forward in season six if he's still
alive and the same goes for other
characters if it works for Morgan you
know there's a good potential that could
work for other characters to the comics
just have so many more characters that
it's kind of like the second half of
season 4 you know we're all day and all
the branching storylines you just you
get a lot more opportunities to see
different places when characters branch
off next question Alana asks so you're
asking like why is you know Pete just
have such easy access to alcohol I think
a lot of that has to do with his value
to the group or his perceived value to
the group by Deanna the funny thing
about this Rick versus Pete stuff is you
can't argue for Pete without sounding
like a Pete apologist so I've been
laughing a little bit watching people
argue that Pete is completely necessary
and it's not such a bad thing that he
beats his wife of course is a terrible
thing that he beats his wife no one is
worth that I think what's gonna happen
is is deanna's decision is gonna bite
her in the ass technically she's not
wrong you know they do need a surgeon
but remember Rick's broken window theory
of society which is kind of funny
because he threw peeped through the
window pete has been breaking windows so
to speak in a metaphorical way for a
long long time now what they should do
is just force him to give basic medical
training to a couple other people next
question Nikki asks what did you think
about Michonne punching Rick well a lot
of people really upset when she did that
because he's her friend I think she was
trying to stop him from making things
way way worse she wasn't siding with
Deanna or Pete she just wanted to keep
Rick from doing something that they
couldn't come back from as it is right
now it's bad but it could have been way
worse if Rick would outright killed him
so Michonne was actually trying to do
the survivors a favor next question
killing it asks who in your opinion is
the true leader of the group Rick does
take on Pete but Carol did tell him to
do it and she sat out on the side could
care i'll be going for the leadership
position no i don't think she's trying
to like outmaneuver Rick or manipulate
him in any way I think she only asked
him to do it because she thought it was
necessary sometimes it's hard to read
what Carol's
really thinking if you remember when she
was first talking to Deanna on tape and
she called herself a den mother I think
she thinks of herself that way she
obviously wasn't telling Deanna all the
awful things that she did as den mother
but I think in her head she thinks Rick
is the best visible leader of the group
like he's the best person to leave the
group he's strong people will rally to
him but he's also another tool in her
arsenal for protecting her den of cubs
so to speak she's not manipulating him
in a sinister way Pete definitely needed
to go obviously things have gotten a
little more complicated now so we'll see
how it plays out and a lot of people
might argue that Carol could have just
killed him herself but think about how
big he is so it would've raised just as
many questions as Rick throwing peeped
through the window next question Epic
Games asks do you think that Glenn or
someone else from Alexandria is gonna
kill Nicholas or is he gonna survive the
season six well I so hope he does not
make it to season six I really feel like
that would be a fun death to see in the
finale he kind of heard Sasha picking
off Walker's at the wall so I'm hoping
they tie him to the Sasha plot and she
just goes apeshit on him that would that
would be a lot of fun remember what
Glenn said to him too he said you don't
go outside those walls by yourself again
later in the episode he went outside the
balls by himself to get the gun that he
stole from Rick I feel like that's a
clear sign something terrible's gonna
happen to him but it's gonna be like a
really good terrible you'll cheer for it
next question j'adore co asks will eat
it becomes sophia from the comics so for
those that haven't rid of the comics
that you know i don't really need to
explain what she does she's just like
another young member of the group that
hangs out with carl lot i would like to
see Enid come on the show in a bigger
way I think it depends on what they do
with the character in the finale there
are a lot of people that are wondering
whether or not she's gonna be tied to
the Wolves like if she's a plant of
wolves plant and she's trying to
infiltrate the community for them
introducing her in a bigger weight like
turning her into a recurring character
would be really interesting for the
coral character so if they're planning
on developing Carl I think they need to
have other people for him to hang out
with a lot of times will happen on
walking dead because the cast is so big
sometimes when they bring guest actors
on if they like their performances the
producers like their performance and
they work really well with the other
characters then they'll continue to
bring them on next question Julia asks
do you think the Enid's going to be
detrimental to Carl survival is there
room for love in the zombie apocalypse
that's funny you know Enid seems like
she knows what's up so I think she will
help Carl I'll be really interested to
see what they do in the finale clearly
there's good it's gonna be like a
two-part situation so I think things are
gonna spiral out of control with this
Rick situation I think Enid's probably
going to help him survive whatever this
wolves threat is going to be the real
question is is like is she part of the
Wolves group and is that how she helps
them survive next question hums e-pro
asks when is Walking Dead coming back
after this so I assume you're talking
about like after the finale when's it
coming back in the fall remember they're
premiering the spin-off show during the
summer like at the end of the summer
it'll be six episodes so probably
what'll happen is they'll run six
episodes up to the first episode of
walking dead season six they haven't
announced an official season six
premiere date but it'll probably the
second week in October like it's always
been so just work backwards six weeks
from that that's like the middle of
August so that's probably when the
spin-off show is gonna premiere so get
really excited it's gonna be like a full
season like a traditional full season of
Walking Dead between the spin-off in the
main show normally like a full season to
TV is like 22 to like 24 episodes thank
you so much everyone for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do don't forget 90-minute finale next
week be sure to subscribe to get my
video if you haven't already I'm gonna
be doing a double giveaway and i'll do
some more bonus videos after my Q&A next
week so don't worry there'll be plenty
of Walking Dead stuff happening they'll
probably start making more announcements
about the spin-off show for the most
part people finish filming pilots by May
so that networks can make decisions on
whether or not they want to pick them up
they've already picked up the spin-off
show for two seasons but the first
season like i said is only six episodes
i know it seems kind of weird what I'm
hoping is is that season two of the
spin-off will get more episodes it'll be
like a full 13 episodes and big high
fives to this week's giveaway winner
spectra XZ you in the amazon gift card
is a twenty-dollar amazon gift card just
message me on the back end of my channel
so I get your contact info why you guys
are holding your breath for the finale
to air you can click here for my episode
15 video if you haven't seen it yet and
you can click here for my latest Game of
Thrones Season 5 video I did it Daenerys
Targaryen video thank you so much for
watching everybody high five I'll see
you guys tonight
you